Hey Youtubers It's Charlie the big news is
that Hulk is going to be a part of Thor Ragnarok
it started out as a little bit of a rumor
then it started to be confirmed by the trades
so if you weren't sure it is definitely a
thing now it doesn't necessarily mean they're
doing any kind of Planet Hulk storyline remember
universal still has the distribution rights
for solo Hulk films so marvel and Disney are
not going to release any solo Hulk films till
they get 100% of the profit participation
that is a whole other story just as the Disney
is like the largest distributor of movies
in the world so they don't like to give money
to other people if they don't have to and
that naturally they don't have to do in the
case a hold so that is can awaited out Mark
Ruffalo though is getting older by the day
and they said that they were so much stuff
going on and Captain America Civil War that
he just didn't make Final Cut they they had
to cut them out of the film so naturally you
can't have Hulk ride the bench for the entirety
of phase 3 so Thor Ragnarok just makes sense
just remember this scene from the first avengers
film think about what they can do with Hulk
on a planet full of as guardians suddenly
the fact that they can heal so fast makes
so much sense now it's going to be like whack
a mole with Thor's hammer just like pounding
them into the ground one at a time it's been
a little while Zometa Thor video but what
they been saying about Ragnarok is that is
closer to Jack Kirby's Ragnarok than the Civil
War clone is been a lot of confusion about
that the minute that they announced it is
a film paper like a mechanic clone Thor is
this is going to be from Civil War kids are
doing Civil War the movies during Civil War
Thor's going to be off planet dealing with
what's going on in Asgard usually with the
visions that he had during avengers interval
Tron about the infinity stones in his absence
is totally possible that they could try to
replicate his power somehow not expecting
any kind of cloning though that would be like
creating another version of all trot it be
like recycling that storyline were Tony Stark
accidentally creates a monster so no Civil
War Ragnarok clone story behind Jack Kirby's
Ragnarok election really interesting obviously
the movies are gonna change a whole bunch
of stuff they were they always do it just
to make a little bit simpler little bit more
linear what happened during Jack Kirby's Ragnarok
is is that his original intention was was
to bring in the new gods and have them replace
the as guardians in Marvel comics Pantheon
of characters think the place that the as
guardian is a Thor Odin that they held in
the comics would become the new gods that
ended up showing up at DC comics is just that
Jack Kirby's contract like he signed a contract
with DC was all going on news is like a small
feud with Marvel toys like fine I'll take
the new guys to DC with them over there so
Ragnarok was kind like this housecleaning
event for marveled he wanted to kill off a
bunch of the as guardian characters they didn't
like in the ones that did come back just came
back that much more hard-core baby do it almost
every single year with the big event just
like the doing with battle world right now
battle world is kind like a trans-dimensional
version of Ragnarok the big thing during that
is the Thor died in was reborn some of the
comic book storylines a minute talk about
might be spoil recent just potential spoilers
for marvels Civil War in the comics not not
the movies just the comics there's a lot of
talk about Captain America maybe dying Bucky
taking the mantle there been so many times
the different characters of died it other
characters of taking their mantle in the comics
that it's really hard to predict what marvels
gonna do I think a lot of it just depends
on which actors re-sign their contracts know
if you remember Kevin Fiege he just took Marvel
studios to like its own separate place that
Disney they essentially have autonomy now
from the rest of marvels operation Kevin Fiege
he has like his own protective bubble to make
a really awesome movies that means that he
can treat his stars a lot nicer so they don't
know bolt for the door the minute their contracts
are up so they can earn more money in a different
studio doing other movies I mean at some point
eventually one of these core avengers is going
to say okay I'm I'm good I've made like 10
billion avengers movies I don't need to do
this anymore please kill me off and fill my
spot with another character was kind of a
phase 3 is about just like opening up the
roster to new characters which is jumping
back to Thor Ragnarok with what the hell is
going on in this movie is in Loki has been
mastering his Odin using Asgard is his own
personal base of operations probably going
to have to pay the piper is in Thanos is probably
going to come in try and raid Odin's weapons
fault and then you have other big characters
like big cosmic villains like fire Lord starter
way way back in the continuity Odin trapped
fire Lord starter with the help of his two
brothers that ended up dying but in the course
of events he was infused with their life force
energy and that became the Odin force if you
want to read like some of those really old
classic Thor stories most of it is on Marvel
unlimited is really cool if you have a couple
weekends to burn there's this there's a lot
of it but essentially think of Hulk's presence
in Thor Ragnarok is like Robert Downey Jr's
presence and Captain America Civil War is
still gonna be a Thor movie Hulk is just going
to be a very important part of it is just
that and Captain America even though Ironman
Robert a Junior major actor he is really like
a smaller part of the film and Captain America's
it's still a Captain America film the US can
let me know like what you want to see Hulk
do with Thor in this movie obviously he's
a good character so is gonna be Odining with
Thor against Loki and you know whoever else
is causing trouble in Asgard hopefully fire
Lord Surtur I'm hoping for like a mega cosmic
villains that will be awesome just expect
them to deliver on the promise of the title
Ragnarok just complete destruction and just
in case there's any confusion about what happened
to Hulk at the end of avengers interval Tron
really think they left ambiguous so they can
do whatever they want to with them like if
something like this happen they can be like
all we want to space or if they didn't want
them to going to space again be like all went
to the bottom of the ocean and he just bailed
out that's the thing about Kevin Fiege and
marvel is they have a plan for every single
character for every single contingencies like
if an actor bails on a contract or if they
become available all of a sudden they just
have multiple ideas for character arcs depending
on who's around and what the circumstances
are whenever they're actually making these
films is actually pretty clever but this is
like a billion-dollar industry so of course
are going to have contingency plans so until
you hear otherwise Hulk is still on planet
Earth they will probably address what's going
on with him during Captain America Civil War
they might just mention it we probably won't
see him if we get really lucky they might
totally pull in illuminati and shoot him into
space the problem is is that you would have
to establish why they would shoot them in
the space and in the comics is because he
freaked out that they would've done and after
this Johannesburg sequence when he went ape
should on everybody and destroyed the city
just more changes from the comic books that
marvels got to do with in the movies they
did a pretty good job of explaining things
on my numbness super worried but I just had
a chance to see Loki and Crimson peak which
is a totally bad ass movie so I'll probably
do a review for that after Doctor Who on Saturday
be sure to subscribe to get that Tom Hiddleston
is awesome minute Jessica Chastain though
she is Queen she is the best part of that
movie I still have a walking deck Q&A to do
so I'll try get that out next and then this
should be Doctor Who maybe a couple trailer
videos in there somewhere that just like a
lot of really awesome footage for everything
this coming right now it is the best time
of year so white as if all the rest that stuff
to post click here to watch the daredevil
season two trailer again what you like 10
more times it's gonna be so awesome punisher
is gonna kick so much as and you can click
here to learn all about Fox and Marvel coming
to an arrangement to do two new TV shows based
on X-Men properties thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five and I'll see you
guys tonight